-I was at a Prince show once.
Couldn't stay in my -- Remember
that time we saw Prince?
-Yes, I do.
-At that party.
And I sat right on the stage
and watched him.
-Are you talking about
the after party
where you got Prince to perform?
-Well, I think me and you
got him to perform.
-Yeah, but that was --
-Really, it was you.
-Yeah, we were
at the "SNL" after party,
and everyone
I could ask for a favor
did me a favor and got onstage.
It was awesome.
Everyone was so nice.
And we had everybody you
could think of getting onstage.
Elvis Costello, Blondie.
-Maya Rudolph was there.
-Taylor Swift, Ariana Grande,
Miley Cyrus.
They all got up --
Paul McCartney.
Everyone was up,
singing, doing --
It was really, honestly
like you wouldn't even believe.
-Didn't, like,
the B-52's go on, too?
-Absolutely. B-52's came on,
and I go,
"What do you want to sing?"
And he goes, "'Love Shack.'"
I go, "Yeah, but do you want to
do, like, 'Mustang Sally'?"
He goes, "'Love Shack'!"
"Alright, dude. Alright."
So, I go to the band --
And the band --
We didn't have a real band.
The band was trying to
figure out "Love Shack."
Like, I don't even know what --
What note is that where
you start "Love Shack"?
♪ See a faded sign ♪
What is that?
-Oh, well...
-Wait. Do that again, Jimmy.
-♪ See at the side of the road ♪
♪ It says "15 miles to the..." ♪
♪ Old shack shimmy ♪
So, everyone's getting onstage,
and then I see you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I see you and I go,
"Dave, what can I do?
What do I do?"
And you go, "Dude, I think --
Prince is here, and I think
if you asked him the right way,
he would come up
and do something.
I go, "Prince? Is Prince here?
I'd love it if you came up
and sang something."
And then everything just
kind of parted.
And then there was like a fog --
Like, a smoke machine came on.
Someone had a portable
smoke machine or something.
And he kind of floated,
like his legs weren't touching.
It was like he kind of
just went like -- like, floated.
Like, his legs --
And he had boots on
and he just kind of
floated to the stage.
And he came up,
and I go, "Oh, my gosh."
And he came up and
he took these long gloves off.
And gave me the gloves,
and I go, "Thank you so much."
And someone threw him a guitar.
He caught the guitar
and he got up
and he sang "Let's Go Crazy."
He sang "Let's Go Crazy."
-Yes, he did.
-And, dude, it was one of
the best things
I've ever seen in my entire --
or been around
in my entire life.
It just --
Everyone was going nuts.
I remember Jay-Z and Beyoncé
were in the crowd.
We're like, "Wow!
Didn't see that coming."
Yeah, they were like, "Well --"
It was giant, man.
But thanks again for doing that.
You were a major role
in getting him to do that.
That was a big night.
-Oh, man that was amazing.